hello everyone and welcome to another
excellent game from defeated 2019 World
Cup in hunt a man Sisk this is a game
from well around one point to the first
game between these two gentlemen Russian
Grandmaster Alexander Rahman of and
Swedish Grandmaster Niels grand alias
ended in a draw so here if either of
them wins that means the other guy is
getting a knocked out of the competition
it's a really nice game really
complicated game really shows you even
grandmasters are sometimes confused in
certain positions and well I enjoyed it
so I hope you will enjoy it as well
a Rachmaninoff opens with c4 so the
English opening is on the board we have
c5 I'll continue in a symmetrical
fashion with Knight to f3 Knight to c6
and now Knight to c3 and E 5 with III by
white preparing the d4 here that's
before Knight to f6 and now d4 as
planned with E for pushing the pawn
further and now Knight to e5 and this is
nothing new this has all been played
before and here g6 is the most played
move here but h5 also unknown move with
Bishop to e2 why prepares the castle and
now Bishop to d6 now with a double
attack on the night here on e5 + f4 here
so you don't want to capture capturing
just allows nice captures back and I
have three and the white is left with a
really strong center so seek after Sun
d4 with ecad for Sun d4 and now Bishop
back to be a this is a like I said all
been played before with castles by white
and now Knight to e7 and here c5 by
white grabbing more space with with some
ideas of maybe a night and go to c4
maybe the knight can come to d6
completely block blacks position and
here Knight the f5 is an old move but
the move black plate is a new move in
the position and that is d6 with C
capture some d6 and it's not a problem
it's not that it's a wrong move or
anything but what black should have done
is played Queen captures on d6 now but
this is a
really a tough position so it's
impossible to predict what's going to
happen black play tonight the FI wit
idea of well recapturing later you can
recapture with the night with the bishop
with the Queen so obviously it's not a
problem but here black is lost now I
know what you're thinking how is black
lost this is a pretty long video and you
know it's 50 some moves in the game well
it's it's only if white plays the
strongest move so feel free to pause the
video here and try to find this elusive
move that white missed in this position
well I give you a couple of seconds so
for those of you who were able to do it
congratulations you are simply an
amazing player and for those who just
won't enjoy the show the move played in
the game is Queen to a4 which is not the
correct which is not the correct move
the Queen is needed to keep an eye on
the h5 point Bishop to b5 check actually
wins the game which is which is pretty
incredible at this point in the game
it's only moved 13 that again could be
concluded between 226 plus grandmasters
the point is that if you block check it
doesn't work and King f8 doesn't work
either for example we can show sorry we
can show Knight to d7 if you go nice to
d7 then just Knight captures on e4 and
then well whatever you decide to do with
black for example if you castle which is
probably what you want to do you don't
want to keep your king strand stranded
in the center you get Bishop to c4 with
an attack against the f7 point and the
Queen is still attacking the h5 pawn so
let's say you go Knight capture some d6
you don't want to capture here otherwise
you get you all out white this massive
point a bone center so you'll play
probably Knight captures on b6 but then
after Knight captures and Bishop
captures finally you get Queen captures
on h5 again with the triple attack
against the f7 point so what you play
here you eliminate one of the attackers
but then the rook also starts attacking
the f7 point and there's really no good
way to defend it for example if you try
Queen here then you get Bishop to h6
really and also move because now Queen
g6 is the threat as the F pawn is pinned
due to the bishop on c4
of course when captors and g7 will be
made and hereafter you capture still
Queen G sex check King h8 you will get
Queen captures and h6 check King g8 and
out rook to a5 and there is no defense
against rock the g5 mate mute good the
DF Pony still pin
you could try Knight captures with the
idea of blocking who would Nyjah sees
but it still doesn't work as the F pawn
is still painted this would still be
made so this is one of the lines that
are possible after Bishop to b5 check if
you block with the night if you work
with the bishop it's a bit different but
Bishop captures on b7 night after Sun b7
and now again Knight captures on e4 and
now still you don't want to capture here
otherwise white gets this massive pawn
Center
you should eliminate this pawn but still
you get Knight captures here and now
Knight to g5 this is just this is just
wonderful and now if you Castle and then
of course Queen captures on h5 you have
an item g5 it's not another pleasant
position and you if you eliminate one of
the attackers for example Knight
captures then you give white this
beautiful pawn chain in the center also
the f7 point is under attack from the
knight and from the rook let's say you
move the knight and I'd be 5 now just
Knight captures on f7 and it's game over
for example Queen captures with check
you can trade here and then just Knight
captures rook and well you wrap a whole
rook so that being said let's let's
check out what what else can you do
after Bishop to b5 check so you can walk
with the knife you can block with the
bishop King f8 is would be the only move
but here comes the idea d7 and this is I
mean to calculate all of this you would
have to invest a lot of time into this
position most likely why why rakhmaninov
missed the idea of Bishop to b5 because
now after Bishop captures Bishop
captures Knight captures you get Queen
to b3 Queen to b3 threatening mate on f7
also attacking the b7 pawn and here
after you eliminate the night for
example Bishop captures you will play F
captures on e5 and now the rook is
attacking the knight you can't really
move the knight you can't move it here
you can't move it here otherwise Bishop
captures
and you're still getting madder than f7
so you can block but then you get Queen
captures on b7 and here
once you try King g7 you want to get
your look into the game white will also
pick up this point and this is just lost
for black you're up two points you have
this amazing point Center and well
slowly but surely black will lose this
game so after night at five it was
actually Bishop to b5 this was the move
but white tried a different player white
right Quinte four check now it's a bit
different because you no longer have
your queen I think that h5 pawn which
was super important in all of the lines
that we've shown King the f8 and now
white continues with a similar plan d7
with Bishop captures Knight captures
with Czech Queen captures Queen captures
so the Queen's are getting traded off
the board Knight captures in the knight
captures on e4 and seems instead of
winning the game right away and move 13
white is now up upon or so the white
would have black thing because black
decided to capture on d4 which also
doesn't work as White has a very strong
attack now even with the Queen's of the
board white played the Queen a sorry
Bishop to c4
the idea is Knight to g5 and going after
the f7 pawn we have Knight b6 going
after the bishop but now White has
really an amazing move also this is a
really good time for you to pause the
video and try to again find the winning
move for white in this position while I
give you a couple of seconds for those
of you who were able to do it really
congratulations again you are an
excellent player and for those of you
who just wanna enjoy the show rook to d1
loop to d1
point being that you cannot trade if you
trade you get rook captures your knight
is under attack you have to move it if
you move it
unless you don't you want to lose it
then comes Rudy eight check and you lose
the rook on h8 so if you don't want to
lose a whole look you have to play
something black found night the c2 and
now he's offering the h8 rook for the a1
rock but it doesn't work we have broody
eight check King the e7 rook captures
and Mountain Knight character Sunday
the problem is how are you going to get
this night back into the game
white played Bishop to d3 taking away
the C 2 square and now you can never
play rook c8 or something because once
you develop the bishop the rooks are
getting traded off but black has this
well at least some play with Bishop to
e5 now once you trade ropes the idea is
of course first Bishop to b4 check and
only then will you recapture so rook
captures on a on a 8 with Bishop to d4
check King f1 and only now Knight
captures on a 8 kink the e2 now you want
to get rid of your dark square Bishop
and then bring the King over to the
knight pick up the night and then you're
just a piece of course in a winning
position black will try to somehow
prevent it in night c7 we have nice to
see 3 and King to d6 Bishop to e3 now it
removed the bishop and then the King
just goes after night or you trade
blight decided to trade with Bishop
captures King captures and King to c5
with King to d2 white is now going after
them stranded knight on a one and now b5
black wants to play B 4 and B 3 either
to try and trade on b3 or to create an
outpost for the night and c2 to at least
give up upon to get the night into the
game 94 check with King to d4 and now
Knight to d6 pressuring both of the
pawns and also threatening Knight f5
check to become the g7 point so while
black is busy trying to figure out how
to get the night out white is just
happily pawn hunting you know with the
night before continuing with the plan of
b3 and trying to somehow get the knight
back into the game but now night at 5
check King back to c5 and of course
Knight captures on g7 going after the h5
pawn we have age for getting the night
getting the pawn out of harm's way and
now Knight back to f5 again going after
the pawn we have Knight to d5 now going
after the f4 pawn but the white decides
yeah that's perfectly fine Knight
captures we have Knight captures and now
b3 preventing black from pushing b3 and
now this Knight is well it's pretty
stranded over there with a 5 by black
and
g3 first pushing the knight back Knight
to d5 and now King to c1 of course now
the knight is being is gonna be captured
or maybe not we'll see what happens
King to d4 now attacking the bishop
bishop to f5 and now King to c3 and now
here you wanna play King to b1 or but
you kind of don't but you have to play
it because after King to be one of
course black will capture the two pawns
and we'll have to connect it passed
pawns here but white is still winning in
this position and this is what white
should have done as it would be much
faster with the route that white Duke he
allowed the black get his Knight back
into the game Knight to f3 but now comes
the Knights to e3 now the problem is
both of the Knights are controlling the
c2 square as well as the King so the
next move the knight is coming back into
the game also you have to react as your
Bishop is under attack here so here
why decided to play g4 with Knight
captures pawn captures and now nice to
see - so the night is back in the game
but black has more problems deep past H
bone is a very fast pawn so first white
played f6 to keep this pawn on f7 so you
can easily attack it with the knight
Knight the e3 black also wants to pick
up the f6 pawn as it's a very dangerous
pawn Knight to e5 and now Knight to d5
the DF bones are getting traded off with
Knight captures Knight captures and now
Knight back to a five so now white is
ready to start pushing the H bond with
Knights the e4 and now h4 and now nice
the g3 would have been a more resilient
defense but still it would not be enough
with a four by black B captures on a
four and now kink the d4 so black
doubled White's pawns
so the King can keep an eye on both of
them with a five by white King to c5 and
now h5 white will now simultaneously be
pushing both of the Kings side and
queenside pawns whereas black will have
to keep an eye on the Queen side pawn
with the King and on the Kings iPhone
with the night so Knight to f6 attacking
the pawn also guarding h7 with h6 and
now king b5 and
now night see for showing off a bit but
you know if it works it works of course
you cannot capture the night because a
six just Queens you cannot go after the
pond good tonight because the night has
to be here to keep an eye on this pond
so black played King gay sex and now
King to d2 white is now just happily
strolling with his King to get rid of
the night and that that is it king b5
with King to d3 with King to a6 King to
e to with King to b5 black is without a
move here you can just repeat moves with
the night or with the king whichever you
prefer King to f3 and it was in this
position that Swedish Grandmaster Niels
grand Elias resigned the game as he can
just you know wait for the inevitable if
you're interested what the inevitable is
here we can just show it king day six
and now you just go after the night king
b5 you go after the night night h7 now
you attack the night mg6 night we'll
check you you're gonna go King G 796
check you're gonna go King f7 and after
this final check 98 you're gonna go King
f6 and now the night can no longer check
you or get near you you are controlling
the important squares the night needs to
go after the pawn and now you're just
gonna play h 7h h queen and that that
wins the game swell after king of three
Greendale has resigned the game and this
means that Alexander Rachmaninoff goes
further into the feeder World Cup which
means he still has a chance at the
candidates tournament whereas it's a
game over for Neil's gonna lose he grabs
his $6,000 and he goes home so that's
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
I would like to thank Sharon zoom and
Fernando esta vez de oliveira for a
contribution to my channel thinking a
lot to really appreciate it as usual you
can check - on my previous video Sarah
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing the coverage of the
fede World Cup 2019 and of course by all
means keep on suggesting games as nice
as this one as I will be mostly going
through your suggestions as there are so
many games being played I can't keep
track of all of them sir thank you I
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day